CORY DOCTOROW: Charlie and I
wrote this book, "The Rapture
of the Nerds." We started
writing it about seven years
ago as a kind of experiment.
Charlie and I had corresponded
and he said, would you like to
collaborate on something?
So he sent me a chunk of the
manuscript, the first 500 or
1,000 words of a story called
"Jury Service." And I read
them and they were quite
gonzo, I mean,
really, really gonzo.
And I thought, all right,
challenge accepted.
So I wrote the most gonzo sort
of follow-on 500 or 1,000
words that I could think of
and sent them back to him.
And then he did the same.
And back and forth we went and
ended up writing this thing
that's very silly
and very fun.
And it was much loved, so much
so that there was a lot of
demand for a sequel, so we wrote
another story called
"Appeals Court."
And those two seemed like they
were unfinished, and Tor asked
us if we would finish them and
do a write-through and turn it
into one book.
So we wrote this third piece,
which is called "Parole
Board." And that's the new chunk
that we're going to read
from a little later today.
And the whole thing with a
thoroughgoing edit became
"Rapture of the Nerds,"
the book but you can
pick up back there.
And I'm going to just say a few
words about kind of the
thematic nature of the book,
and then Charlie will say a
few words as well.
And then we'll each do
a brief reading.
The title "Rapture of the Nerds"
comes from another
writer, Ken McLeod--
Scottish, Trotskyist, science
fiction writer of some great
merit and thoughtfulness.
And Ken was one of the first
people to notice that the
Singularity bears a market
similarity to the notion of
the Rapture and the "Left
Behind" novels, and this idea
that there will come a time
when people who possess a
specific virtue will disappear
from the Earth, leaving only
the virtuous behind.
Only instead of people who have
faithfully adhered to
Bronze Age doctrine going away
to heaven, this would be
techies and nerds and skeptics
and math people who would be
comfortable with having their
brains stuck in computers and
being disassembled here on Earth
and uploaded to a cloud.
So that's the notion of the
book, is to try and sort of
explore an inverse of being left
behind, a "Left Behind"
where the people left behind
are the people who are
skeptical about uploading.
And it's something that I like
to think of as the progressive
apocalypse.
So before the Enlightenment,
we had this idea of
lapsarianism, the idea that
things were getting worse and
worse every year, that we were
kicked out of the Garden and
every year that went by,
we fell further and
further from grace.
And it's kind of easy to
understand how lapsarianism
would seem like an a natural,
incredible idea.
After all, by the time you hit
sort of the last 10% of your
natural lifespan, it seems
pretty apparent that things
are getting worse.
After all, didn't everything
used to taste better?
And didn't everything used
to smell better?
Weren't the people of your
preferred gender prettier?
Didn't you hurt less?
I mean, clearly the world is
a worse place than it was.
And I think even the human
imagination balks
at unbounded systems.
We think, well, if things are
going to get worse and worse,
eventually they'll reach a point
of, as Spinal Tap would
have put it, "none more worse."
And that "none more
worse" is the Apocalypse,
right?
When things can't get any more
worse, you have a break.
Everything comes to
a crashing halt.
Now along comes the
Enlightenment and the idea
that things are just going to
get better, that we will stand
on the shoulders of giants, and
then people stand on our
shoulders, and then they'll
stand on theirs, and so on,
all the way up to the
contemporary notion of Moore's
law and the idea that things are
getting better and better.
And again, we confront this
unbounded system and we go,
well, there must come a time
when things can get none more
better, when the balloon has
inflated so much that it
bursts and we reach a
break with history.
We cease to be humans
as we understand it.
And that's the other theme that
we explore in this book,
this idea that the Singularity
is in many ways attractive not
because it's credible, but
because our brain likes the
idea of a bounding
condition on this
otherwise unbounded system.
So that's the book, and I'm
going to let Charlie talk
about it a bit first and
then do some reading.
And then I'll come back and do
some reading, and then we'll
take your questions.
CHARLES STROSS: Well,
so, the Singularity.
It's an interesting term.
It really got introduced in
the science fiction field
around 1992 by Vernor Vinge, who
you've probably heard of
and may well have read.
Science fiction writer, Hugo
Nebula winner, also a
now-retired professor
of computer science.
Vernor's version of a
singularity was a lot more
constrained and, dare I say it,
grounded than the version
that's become common
currency among
transhumanists these days.
Vernor's resolution was
essentially a hypothesis about
artificial intelligence,
that if we can build a
human-equivalent AI, then it
should, in principle, be
possible to make it think faster
than a regular human
being just by throwing more
computing resources at it,
assuming it's not
bottlenecked--
which it has the brain as
a thoroughly parallel
architecture.
There's no reason to suppose
it would be.
He also speculated further
that if there are
fundamentally more powerful
modes of cognition than human
consciousness, if there are
forms of intelligence that are
as much more powerful than our
thinking as we are than, say,
a frog, then once you have
really, really, really fast
human-equivalent AIs, they will
make a breakthrough to a
strongly transhuman form of
intelligence, if such a
breakthrough is possible
at all.
And at that point, the brakes
are off and we are not setting
the agenda for the universe
we inhabit.
This was Vernor's original
context for singularity.
And he wrote some novels about
it, starting from, I think,
the late 1980s with "Marooned in
Realtime" and "Subsequent."
But it wasn't long before this
cross-fertilized with some
interesting, in subcultures
relating to each other via the
internet-- the early
transhumanists, the
Extropians.
I don't know if anyone here was
on the Extropians mailing
list in the late '80s,
early '90s.
I see some recognition.
And like a giant Katamari of
weird ideas, it began sort of
accreting baggage as
it rolled downhill.
Among the bits of baggage
it acquired--
well, molecular nanotechnology
and magic nanite pixie dust
probably need no further
explanation.
But mind uploading, the idea
that we can dissect bits of
our brains, analyze the signal
processing therein, and
ultimately port whatever
representation we have of a
human mind to run on
different hardware.
And of course, once we are
running in a computer, there's
no reason we can't make our sim
very pleasant to live in.
It's AI Heaven time.
And hey, we're all going to
flying up into the computers,
live in the Google Cloud
for that matter.
I'm not sure that's such a
good idea, but I digress.
[LAUGHTER]
CHARLES STROSS: And this sort
of began accreting all sorts
of theological baggage.
It got to the point where I
found myself being sort of
pinned into corners at SF
conventions by people with no
context of personal space who
wanted to know how long it
would be before they could
abandon the meat puppet.
[LAUGHTER]
CHARLES STROSS: Now this
struck me as slightly
disturbing.
And when one goes looking for
parallels, it doesn't take
long to find them.
From around 950 AD onwards,
Western Europe was sort of hit
by wave after wave of cults,
if you like, where the
peasants would sort of abandon
their farms, abandon their
clothes, trash the joint and
go and form free-love
communes, marauding around
Europe, because they knew
Jesus was going to come and
spirit them away to heaven
within the next few weeks.
And this sort of kept up for
about 50 to 100 years,
periodically being put
down by [INAUDIBLE]
by the nobility, with the
enthusiastic backing of the
Church, who disapproved
of this kind of thing.
But it has had echoes
ever since.
Christian eschatology came up
with the Revelation of St.
John around the second century,
and ever since then,
as Cory noted, there has been
the apocalyptic trend embedded
very deeply in our culture.
If we fast forward to the 18th
century and the Scottish
Enlightenment, we have
a changeover--
to some extent a reaction
against a very dire,
fundamentalist, Presbyterian
theology of the theocracy that
ran Scotland for a couple
of centuries until
the early 18th century--
resulting in a new more
optimistic vision of the world
whereby things can get better
and better all the time and we
can improve ourselves.
But it's still the same
apocalyptic imagery and urge.
And "The Rapture of the Nerds"
was, to some extent, an
attempt to grapple with the
theological and aesthetic
underpinnings of
Singularitarianism.
More recently, if you want to
find the missing link to the
Extropians and the
transhumanists, you really
need to look at the 1920s
Russian movement
known as the Cosmists.
If you think sort of 1920s
Russian revolutionary
Communist Extropians--
most of them would be American
libertarians these days--
that's where you find them.
They got their scheme from a
theologian, Nikolai Fedorov,
late 19th-century
Russian Orthodox
theologian and teacher.
He taught Konstantin
Tsiolkovsky, the father of
rocketry among other things.
And the Fedorov came up with
an almost barking teleology
framed in terms of Christian
thought.
First of all, given that we have
a theological impetus to
improve ourselves towards
perfection, to converge with
godliness, Fedorov concluded
that a necessary step on this
was the complete unification
of humanity and the
abolition of war.
How do you do this?
Well, you find them something
more important to wage on--
like, say, death.
So Fedorov came up with this
proposal that we should work
on human immortality, expansion
into space, giving
human beings the ability to
photosynthesize and move
between worlds.
We're talking 1890s here,
I should add.
And this, however, was not
where the buck stopped.
Because let us suppose we've
inherited the entire cosmos,
we're de facto omnipotent
and immortal.
It is an insult to our existence
that there are still
human beings moldering in the
grave, that we must therefore
then seek to resurrect every
human being who had ever
lived, and moreover, every human
being on every timeline
that could have given rise
to the present day.
Now if you put that in your pipe
and smoke it, it's some
pretty heady stuff.
And as I said, this stuff--
1920s Leninists?
1890s Russian Orthodox Christian
theologians?
2010 Raymond Kurzweil?
It has what the police in the
UK refer to as "form." You
know, it's come up on
their radar before.
Shall I start?
CORY DOCTOROW: Yeah.
You're reading.
CHARLES STROSS: And so I'd like
to read a chunk to you
today, if I can get this machine
to recognize me,
explaining how Huw
finds himself--
Huw, our protagonist, finds
herself, I should add.
Huw started out male and ends
up female and it gets
complicated thereafter.
[LAUGHTER]
CHARLES STROSS: How Huw ends up
in the digital afterlife.
And I should add, Huw is a
curmudgeonly Welsh Green who
runs a pottery and trusts no
technology more complex than
his bicycle.
CORY DOCTOROW: Her.
CHARLES STROSS: Her,
by this point.
[LAUGHTER]
CHARLES STROSS: No, the--
I thought the bike
had been crushed.
Anyway.
CORY DOCTOROW: Continuity.
CHARLES STROSS: Continuity.
[LAUGHTER]
CHARLES STROSS: Huw--
CORY DOCTOROW: It's
a new bike.
CHARLES STROSS: Yeah.
It's a new bike.
Huw is holding her right hand
under the cold-water tap and
swearing when there's another
knock at the door.
"Who is it?" she calls
down the hall.
"It's the Singularity," a
booming voice replies.
"What do you want?"
"Everything is different now!"
"I don't want any."
"If I could just have a moment
of your time?" It takes a lot
of skill to make a stentorian
voicebox emit a credible
wheedle, but the bell ringer
at the door has clearly
practiced it to a fine art.
Huw turns the faucet back up and
puts her fingers into the
cold stream.
There are vicious little burns,
red welts that her
honest, baseline human
cells will take
weeks to properly heal.
Of course, you could just ride
over to the McNanite's and get
some salve that'd make them
vanish before her eyes, but
Huw's endured much worse and she
still got enough stubborn
stockpiled to last her
a couple of eons.
There's another thud
at the door.
Thud.
Thudthudthud.
Then a transhuman tattoo of
thuds in rising frequency,
individual thuds blurring into a
composite buzz that gets the
bones of the old house
rattling in sympathy,
shivering down little hisses
of plaster dust from the
joints in the ceiling.
Huw uses her good hand to wrench
the faucet off, then
wraps a tea towel around her
throbbing, dripping fingers
and walks to the door, gritting
her teeth with every
step as she forces herself
not to run.
It feels like the house might
rattle down around her ears
any second, but she won't give
the infinity-botherer outside
the satisfaction.
She opens the door with the
same measured calm.
Let one of these fundies know
you're on edge, and he'll try
to grab the psychological
advantage and work it until
you agree to his balls.
Sorry.
Pitch.
Freudian slip there.
[LAUGHTER]
"I said," Huw says, "I
don't want any."
"I'm afraid I rather must
insist," says the
infinity-botherer through his
augmented, celestial voicebox.
The first of that voice makes
Huw take an involuntary
wincing step backwards, like
a blast from an air horn.
"Huw, this is mandatory,
not optional.
This is mandatory,
The words send Huw whirling back
through time, back to her
boyhood, and a million
repetitions and variations on
this phrase from his--
"Mum?" she asks, jaw dropping as
she stares up at the giant
borg on the doorstep.
It's at least three meters high,
silvery and fluid, thin
as a schwa, all ashimmer
with otherworldly
transcendent wossname.
It's neither beautiful nor
handsome, though it's
intensely aesthetically pleasing
in a way that demands
some sort of genderless
superlative that no human
language has ever managed.
Huw hates it instantly--
especially since she suspects at
the loa riding it might be
descended from one of
his awful parents.
"Yes, dear," the Singularity
booms.
"I like the regendering.
It really suits you.
Your father would send his best,
by the way, if he was
still hanging around
the solar system."
Huw last saw her parents
at their disembodiment.
They'd already had avatars
running around in the cloud
for years, dipping into
meatspace every now and again
for a resynch with
their slowcode
bioinstances dirtside.
When they were finally
deconstituted into a fine
powder of component molecules,
it'd been a technicality
really, a final flourish in
their transhumanunification.
But the finality of it, zero out
their bodies, had marked a
break for Huw.
Mum and Dad were now
technically dead.
They were technically
alive, too, but that
was beside the point.
Until Mum donned a golem
and came to talk.
"Mum, I don't talk to dead
people," Huw says.
"Go away." She deliberately does
not slam the door, but
closes it, and turns the latch,
and heads back to the
sink, deliberately ignoring the
fragments of cloud wearing
her mum's memories.
She manages to go three steps
before the door splinters and
tears loose of its hinges,
thudding to the painstakingly
restored tile floor in the
front hall with a merry
tinkling of shattered
antique glass.
"Love, I know you're not best
pleased to see me, but you've
been summoned, and
that's that."
The spirit of adolescence
descends on Huw in a red mist.
Her mum has always been able to
reduce her to a screeching
teakettle of resentment.
"Get out my house, mum!
I hate you!"
Her mum's avatar grabs Huw in a
vicious hug that feels like
foam rubber paddings wrapped
around titanium armatures.
"Poor thing," it says.
I know it's been hard for you.
We did our best, you know, but
well, we were only human.
Now, come along, sweetie."
It's Tripoli all over again, but
this time the golem whose
grasp she can't escape emits
a steady stream of basso
profundo validations of Huw's
many gifts and talents and how
proud her parents are of all
she's achieved and suchlike.
Huy tries to signal a
beedlemote, but her mum's got
some kind of diplomatic
semaphore that makes all the
enforcementware give
it free passage.
Mum's bot stops at every traffic
signal, and several
times, Huw tries to get
passersby by to help her, with
lines like, "I'm being kidnapped
by the bloody
Singularity!"
Unfortunately, nobody seems
interested in lending a hand.
And even if they did, Mum goes
about 200 kilometers per hour
between traffic lights, her gait
so fast that every time
Huw opens her mouth to screen,
it fills with wind and her
cheeks wibble and wobble while
she tries to breathe past the
air battering at her windpipe.
Then they've arrived.
The alien consulate is midfab,
its hairy fractal edges
radiating heat as nanites
grab matter out of the
sky to add to it.
The actual walls are only waist
high, though the spindly
plumbing, mains, and network
infrastructure are already in
place and teeter skyward like
a disembodied nervous system
filled with dye for an
anatomical illustration.
The consul is an infinitely
hot and dense dot of
eyeball-warping fuzz in the
exact center of what will be
the ground floor.
Well, it's not exactly infinite,
but it does seem to
bend the light around it, and it
certainly radiates too much
heat to approach closely.
"Thank you for coming,"
it says.
"You brought your invitation, I
hope?" "Fuck you!
No!" Huw screams.
She's gathering breath for
another outburst, but Mum
shakes her--
gently by golem standards, but
hard enough to rattle the
teeth in her jaws.
"Bad idea, darling." A palpable
cone of silence
descends around Huw's ears as
Mum confides, "When I said it
was mandatory, I was serious.
If you don't comply, it'll
delete everyone."
"Fuuuu--" Huw pauses.
"Delete?" She realizes that
everything outside the cone of
silence has stopped, stuck in a
bizarre meatspace cognate of
bullet time--
that's hanging on the wing in
midair, leaves frozen in
midfall, that sort of thing.
"Yes, dear.
I'm not exaggerating.
It's come to pass a visit from
the Next Level, and faster,
smarter thinkers than you or I
are crapping themselves." Huw
is rattled.
Mum always had an accurate
appreciation of her own
abilities, and as a Fields
Medal winner, she wasn't
inclined to hide them
under a bushel.
"But it's playing by the
rules, apparentl.
There's got to be a
Public Inquiry.
Which means statements by
witnesses and friends of the
court and so on and so forth--
all very tiresome, I'm sure,
but it seems your name came
out of the hat first.
So I'm afraid you're back on
jury duty, like it or not.
If it's any consolation, I'll
try to make this painless."
The birds and the bees resume
their respective chirping and
buzzing as the cone of silence
collapses on Huw like an icy
waterfall of fear.
"Shitbiscuits!" she screams as
Mum gently wraps a band of
silvery-shimmering
nanomanipulators around Huw's
head and saws off the
top of her skull.
Over to Cory.
[APPLAUSE]
CORY DOCTOROW: So as you've just
heard, Huw is forcibly
transcended.
And later on in the story, the
section I'm going to read,
she's finally been taken off to
the galactic civilization's
holding pen for expert
witnesses, which is a giant,
tasteless replica of the Burj
Khalifa made out of the bones
of the moons of Jupiter, which
have been co-opted as a
temporary computronium
outpost.
It's so tasteless that the
doorman is a giant gorilla.
"I hope you enjoy the facilities
here," says the
gorilla, with a wink.
"Nothing but the best for
our expert witnesses--
we have hot and cold running
everything."
It's a far cry from jury duty
accommodation in the crappy
backpacker's hostel
in dusty Tripoli.
Huw dials her time right up
(sinfully extravagant) and
orders the whirlpool-equipped
hot tub with champagne to
appear in the bathroom.
Then she climbs in to marinate
for subjective hours (a
handful of seconds in everyone
else's timeframe) and to
unkink for the first
time in ages.
After all, it's not as though
she's consuming
real resources here.
And she needs to relax, needs
to recenter her emotions the
natural way, and do some
serious plotting.
Of course, the sim is
far too realistic.
A virtual champagne bath should
somehow manage to keep
the champagne
drinking-temperature cold
while still feeling
warm to the touch.
And it shouldn't be sticky
and hot and flat.
It should feel like champagne
does when
it hits your tongue--
icy, bubbly, and fizzy.
And when Huw's non-bladder feels
uncomfortably full and
relaxed in the hot liquid and
she lets loose a surreptitious
stream, it should be magicked
away, not instantly blended in
with the vintage Veuve Clicquot
to make an instant
tub's worth of piss mimosa.
[LAUGHTER]
This is what comes of having too
much compute-time at one's
disposal, Huw seethes.
In constraint, there is
discipline, the need to choose
how much reality you're going
to import and model.
Sitting on an Io's worth of
computronium has freed the
Galactic Authority--
and isn't that an imaginative
corker of a name?--
from having to choose.
And with her own self simulated
as hot and wide as
she can be bothered with, she
can feel every unpleasant
sensation, each individual
sticky bubble, each droplet
clinging to her body as she hops
out of the tub and into a
six-jet steam-shower for a
top-to-bottom rinse, and then
grabs a towel--
every fiber slightly stiff and
plasticky, as if fresh out of
the wrapper and never
properly laundered
to relax the fibers--
and she dries off.
She discovers that she is
hyperaware, hyperalert,
feeling every grain of not-dust
in the not-air
individually as it collides
with her not-skin.
Oh, enough, she wants
to shout.
What is the point of
all this rubbish?
This is the thing that Huw has
never wanted to admit.
Her primary beef against the
Singularity has never been
existential--
it's aesthetic.
The power to be a being of pure
thought, the unlimited,
unconstrained world of
imagination, and we build a
world of animated gifs, stupid
sight gags, lame van-art
avatars, brain-dead "playful"
environments, and brain-dead
flame wars augmented by animated
emoticons that allow
participants to express their
hackneyed ad hominems,
concern-trollery, and violations
of Godwin's law
through the media of
cartoon animals and
oversized animated genitals.
Whether or not sim-Huw is really
Huw, whether or not
uploading is a kind of death,
whether or not posthumanity is
immortal or just kidding itself,
the single inviolable
fact remains.
Humans simspace is no more
tasteful than the
architectural train wreck
that the Galactic
Authority has erected.
The people who live in it have
all the aesthetic sense of a
senile jackdaw.
Huw is prepared to accept--
for the sake
of argument, mind--
that uploading leaves your soul
intact, but she is never
going to give one nanometer
on the question of whether
uploading leaves your
taste intact.
If the Turing test measure an
AI's capacity to conduct
itself with a sense of real
style, all of simspace would
be revealed for a
machine-sham.
Give humanity a truly unlimited
field, and it would
fill it with Happy Meal toys and
holographic, sport-star,
collectible trading
card game art.
There's a whole gang of dirtside
refuseniks to make
this their primary objective
to transcendence.
They're severe Bauhause
cosplayers, so immaculately
and plainly turned out that
they look more like
illustrations than humans.
Huw's never felt any
affinity for them--
too cringeworthy, to like a
Southern belle who comes down
with the vapors at the sight of
a fish knife laying where
the dessert fork
is meant to go.
It's always felt unserious to
object to a major debate over
human evolution with an
argument about style.
But Huw appreciates their point,
and has spent his and
then her entire life complaining
instead about the
ineffable and undefinable
humanness that is lost when
someone departs for the cloud.
She's turned her back on her
parents, refused to take their
calls from beyond the grave,
she's shut herself up in her
pottery with only the barest
vestige of a social life,
remade herself as someone who is
both a defender of humanity
and a misanthrope.
All the while, she's
insisted--
mostly to herself, because, as
she now sees with glittering
clarity, no one else
gave a shit--
that the source of her concerns
all along has been
metaphysical.
The reality that stares her in
the face now, as she reclines
on the impeccably rendered
20-million-count non-Egyptian
noncotton nonsheets, is that
it's always been a perfectly
normal, absolutely subjective,
totally meaningless dispute
about color schemes.
And now she's got existential
angst.
The Burj Khalifa's in-room TV
gets an infinity of channels,
evidently cross-wired
from the cable feed
for Hilbert's hotel.
It uses some--
[LAUGHTER]
It uses some evolutionary
computing system to generate
new programs on the fly,
every time you press
the channel-up button.
This isn't nearly as banal as
Huw imagined it might be when
she read about it on the
triangular-folded cardboard
standup that materialized in her
hand when she reached for
the remote.
That's because--
as the card explained--
the Burj has enough computation
to model captive
versions of Huw at extremely
high speed, and to tailor the
programming by sharpening
its teeth against those
instances-in-a-bottle so that
every press of the button
brings up eye-catching,
attention-snaring material.
It's mostly soft-core
pornography
that involves pottery.
[LAUGHTER]
Huw would like nothing better
than to relax with the
goggle-box and let her mind
be lovingly swaddled in
intellectual flannel, but her
mind isn't having any of it.
The more broadly parallel she
runs, the more meta-cognition
she finds herself mired in, so
that even as she lies abed,
propped up on a hill of pillows
the size of a Celtic
burial mound, her thoughts are
doing something like this.
Oh.
That's interesting.
Never thought of doing that
sort of thing with glaze.
Oh, too interesting.
If you ask me, it's not
natural, that kind of
interesting.
They've got to be simulating
gigaHuws to come up with that
sort of realtime optimization.
There'll be hordes of Huw
instances being subjected to
much-less-interesting versions
of this program and winking
out of existence as soon
as they get bored.
Hell, I could be one of those
instances, my life dangling by
a frayed thread of attention.
Every time I press the
channel-up button, I execute
thousands--
millions?
billions?--
of copies of myself.
Why don't I care more
about them?
It's insane and profligate
cruelty but here's me blithely
pressing the channel-up
button.
Whoa, that's interesting--
she looks awfully like Bonnie,
but with a bum that's a little
bit more like that girl
I fancied in college.
I could die at any instant, just
by losing attention and
pressing channel-up.
That's wild, I never noticed
how those muscles--
the quadrati lumborum?--
spring out when someone's at
the wheel, that bloke's got
QL's for days.
If I were really aesthetically
opposed to this sort of thing,
I'd be vomming in my mouth with
rage at the thought of
all those virtual people
springing into existence and
being snuffed out.
But I'm not, am I?
Hypocrite, liar, poseur, mincing
aesthete, that's me.
So long as it's interesting
and stylish,
I'll forgive anything.
I've got as much existential
introspection as a Mario sprite.
Enough, already, she tells
herself, and cools herself
down to a single thread, then
throws that down, hunting for
the sweet spot at the junction
of stupidity and calm.
Then finding it, she settles
down and watches TV for one
hundred subjective years,
slaughtering invisible hordes
of herself without a moment's
further thought.
Satori.
So that's the reading.
[APPLAUSE]
we're on there is
a power button.
Or is that controlled
of a console?
So we're now free to take
your questions.
We can share the mic
if we can't figure
out how to get one.
How many science fiction writers
does it take to turn
on a wireless mic?
All of them, apparently.
So are there any questions?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Would I be correct
in guessing that you wrote
sections primarily
by yourselves?
CORY DOCTOROW: Uh, no.
CHARLES STROSS: I
don't think so.
CORY DOCTOROW: No.
They really-- there's a lot of
thought of interwriting in
both of those passages.
They're really interwritten,
those two, particularly.
Those are among the passages
where, when I read them, I'm
like, that looks like my tick
and that looks like Charlies
tick and who the fuck
wrote that?
[LAUGHTER]
CHARLES STROSS: Yeah.
We were swapping over about
every 500 to 1,000 words, and
both of the passages we read are
well over 1,000 words, so.
CORY DOCTOROW: And we did
lots of re-editing of
each other's stuff.
So there are some interesting
offcuts lying around in our
hard drives, too.
Other questions?
We actually could figure out who
wrote those, because I at
least did version control
with them.
I--
a friend of mine wrote me some
Python scripts that are in
GitHub called flashbake, and
every 15 minutes, they grab
all my working files and then
they check them into a local
Git repo with the--
it figures out what time zone
I'm in from my IP address,
where I am from my IP address,
the last three songs I
listened to, the last three
headlines I posted on Boing
Boing," and then and logs it.
And I figure, you know, in like
10 years, it'll be kind
of interesting to go back
and look over it.
I've also been thinking that I
could probably do something
more interesting these days,
like take a picture every 15
minutes and--
CHARLES STROSS: Blood
pressure.
CORY DOCTOROW: Blood pressure
from the picture.
Skin galvanometry, skin response
from the touch pad.
And probably more.
I mean, I'm sure, like,
eventually the mic will be
sensitive enough to grab
things like heart
rate and so on, too.
AUDIENCE: Is that
Thomas Gideon?
CORY DOCTOROW: That's
Thomas Gideon, yeah.
He's a good guy.
You know him?
He has a great podcast called
"The Command Line." And he
works for New America
Foundation now.
He's one of the
internet-in-a-box guys.
CHARLES STROSS: I like
living dangerously.
I just basically left
my backups to Time
Machine on the laptop.
Having said that, we worked on
this as just a markdown file
bounced back and forth in email,
and as long as the
email folders are thoroughly
backed up, I've got different
snapshots all the way through.
CORY DOCTOROW: Yeah.
I mean, this all started with
the Merril Collection in
Toronto, which is the largest
public science fiction
reference library in the world,
started by Judy Merril,
who was kind of my mentor
when I was younger.
They logged my papers for me.
Because when I started selling
novels, I was moving
continents like every
18 months.
And especially back then, every
novel you sold involved
three lumps of paper at
least about this big.
There was the initial
manuscript, and then the
marked-up manuscript, and then
the typed script, and so on.
And there was no way I
could manage them.
And so they just keep my papers
for me, and one day,
the head librarian, Lorna
Toolis, said, you know, it's
such a pity, because in the
old days, we used to get
multiple distinct drafts
from our writers.
And this was obviously very
interesting to scholars in
subsequent years.
And now there's just kind of
the rolling text file that
then gets turned into a book.
If only there were some way
to keep track of the
changes to a text file.
[LAUGHTER]
CORY DOCTOROW: And I was like,
you know, this is the
canonical solved
problem, right?
So that's where it
all started.
Are there other questions?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
CHARLES STROSS: We will talk
about it at the end of this
talk, if we haven't strangled
each other first.
CORY DOCTOROW: Yeah, I mean,
everything is possible.
We might upload and fork new
instances to work on books
together or something.
CHARLES STROSS: Yeah.
CORY DOCTOROW: It's possible.
We both have a lot of stuff
on the go at the moment.
And we are-- we're both
contributing to a project,
although we're not collaborating
directly on it.
Neal Stephenson is working on
this thing, "Hieroglyphics,"
with Arizona State.
It's science fiction stories
built on real science,
credible, sort of plausible
science.
I'm working on a story about
Burners who create a
playa-dust printer that is so
successful, they drop it on
the Playa at Fourth of Juplaya
celebration at the start of
the summer, and by Labor Day
weekend, it's printed out
their yurt.
And they live in it for Burning
Man, and then they
chop it up into pieces
and pack it out.
And they're so happy with it
that they decide to build one
that does luna rigala.
And they use a private
space-exploration vehicle to
drop one on the moon, and
they spend a generation
reprogramming its firmware by
bouncing hand signals off the
moon and building a lunar
habitat that their
grandchildren can move into.
And Charlie, what story
are you working on?
CHARLES STROSS: Well, I was
meant to be working on the
third of a trilogy beginning
with "Halting
State" and "Rule 34"--
this being the political
one titled "The Lambda
Functionary." But it's going to
take me about two years to
write as it's sort of
set 15 years out.
And trying to do near-future
SF like that is really hard
these days, thanks to
people like you.
[LAUGHTER]
So I'm negotiating with my agent
to hand in a different--
the fifth "Laundry"
novel instead.
CORY DOCTOROW: But what are
you working on for Neal?
For the "Hieroglyph" thing?
CHARLES STROSS: I haven't even
confirmed I'm on that yet.
I want to be, but I'm juggling
too many balls right now.
CORY DOCTOROW: Seth.
AUDIENCE: So did guys have
many parts of this?
Like when you're collaborating
on a shared work like this,
are there parts of it that
you had to give up?
CORY DOCTOROW: Maybe not that we
wish we could've kept, but
there's definitely big chunks
that got off-cut.
CHARLES STROSS: Yeah, a lot of
arguing over whether something
belonged in it and
then rewriting.
CORY DOCTOROW: Yeah.
There's nothing that I like more
and overmuch, but there's
plenty of stuff on cutting-room
floor.
CHARLES STROSS: I mean, think of
it as a kind of half-assed
version of pair programming if
you emailing source files back
and forth to each other and
working 400 miles apart rather
than the same room.
CORY DOCTOROW: Yeah.
You know, I just read an early
edition of the new David Byrne
book, "How Music Works." It's an
amazing book, and there's a
section in it on how we
collaborated with Eno on
"Everything That Happens Will
Happen Today," the album they
did a couple of years ago.
And Eno had actually written
all the melodies.
And so he just-- they were sort
of sitting on his hard
drive, and so he fired
them off to Byrne.
And then Byrne figured
out the words.
And he was like, I could go
back and ask for, like,
melodic changes, but there's
kind of a hassle to that, so
I'm just going to work with
this as a constraint.
It's a pretty interesting
passage in a
very, very good book.
I heartily recommend it.
It'll be out in about a week.
I've got a review queued up on
Boing Boing that may remind
you, if you read Boing Boing.
Scott, you had a question.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
CORY DOCTOROW: I mean, I think
it would have been bad form to
do too much in one go.
CHARLES STROSS: Yeah, but the
main thing was to keep
momentum going so we
had to turn it
around within 48 hours.
And you know, 500 to 1,000 is
a reasonable day's polished
output, especially when
you're trying to do
something high concept.
CORY DOCTOROW: And when you're
rewriting the stuff that came
before, so you're taking a pass
through the piece that
came before.
CHARLES STROSS: I think the
longest chunk I mailed to Cory
at one point was about 2,500
words, at a time when you were
traveling and not able to work
on it for a couple of days.
CORY DOCTOROW: Yeah.
And you know, that's about how
I did it, I did that novella
with Ben Rosenbaum, "True
Names," and that's about how
we did that too.
Although Ben--
Ben likes to talk a lot about
what you're writing.
He used to send me long, like,
so here's what I'm thinking.
I don't know if you've ever met
Ben, or heard him talk.
It comes through.
It's like-- (FRANTICALLY) So
here's what I'm thinking.
There's this thing.
And there's another thing.
And this other thing.
And I'd be, like, yeah, Ben?
Can we just write it?
I know, I know.
I know.
And he was like, I overthinking
it again.
We were a little more compatible
in that regard.
There was less--
less foreplay, more of
the important stuff.
[LAUGHTER]
CHARLES STROSS: I didn't
know you cared.
CORY DOCTOROW: Yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
CORY DOCTOROW: Would
Google Docs be more
beneficial of less?
CHARLES STROSS: This probably
isn't the right venue to
confess that I hate, loathe,
and fear cloud computing
systems but don't
actually have an
in-my-pocket fall-back.
The trouble of Google Docs for
this sort of thing, first,
you'd be working on one long
continual scrolling text.
And by the time you're up to
about 90,000 words, Google
Docs is not terribly happy.
The other aspect is it requires
you to be online with
a good internet connection.
And if you're traveling or you
live somewhere where the
internet is up or down, that's
not so good either.
CORY DOCTOROW: And in
particular, if those moments
in which there's no network are
the moments that you're
like, oh, wow, there's nothing
else that I can be doing right
now, no high-priority items
that I can take care of
because I've got network
access, now's the
moment I can write.
Then Google Docs is no
good to you at all.
I've got the sequel to "Little
Brother" coming out in
February, and I wrote big chunks
of that, I write that
like 2,000 words a day, and
I did it while touring.
And a lot of it while
touring Germany.
So the German tour is
really interesting.
I was touring a young adult
book, so I would go to schools
with my translator.
My translator would read for
half an hour, and then I'd
read for half an hour,
because, you
know, they're Europeans.
They speak better English
than I do.
And while my translator was
reading in German, I would
have half an hour to sit there
on stage and write.
And if I'd needed network
access, I would've been hosed.
I never would have finished
that book.
AUDIENCE: First of all, I loved
the reference to "I was
an infinitely hot
and dense dot."
CORY DOCTOROW: Yeah.
Mark Leyner.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
That was really my introduction,
in a lot of
ways, to [INAUDIBLE].
But the other thing I was going
to ask is I was actually
introduced to your writing
by Paul Krugman's blogs.
And I was just wondering
if you--
he's never mentioned meeting
you, that I've read, but I was
just wondering--
CHARLES STROSS: Oh,
yeah, we have met.
It was at the World Science
Fiction Convention about three
years ago in Montreal, where
they sort of arranged to put
us on stage.
And it's the second most
terrifying thing I've ever
done on stage, is go up on stage
in front of 1,000 people
and cameras with Paul
Krugman and try not
to look like a fool.
CORY DOCTOROW: It's on YouTube.
[LAUGHTER]
CHARLES STROSS: Note,
I say the second
most terrifying thing.
[LAUGHTER]
CHARLES STROSS: To give you
something but exceeds that for
sheer blind terror was a event
about 15 years ago, when I
went on stage while a guy who
was into medieval longsword
reenactment demonstrated
killing strokes with a
broadsword, using
me as a model.
[LAUGHTER]
CHARLES STROSS: And what I knew
and the audience didn't
know was that this guy had
macular degeneration and was
registered blind.
He only had 2% of his
visual field left.
[LAUGHTER]
CORY DOCTOROW: Wow.
CHARLES STROSS: Going up with
Paul Krugman was sort of the
intellectual equivalent.
[LAUGHTER]
CORY DOCTOROW: Are you
think Paul's blind?
CHARLES STROSS: No, I'm saying
he's the equivalent of the
sort of blind sensei.
CORY DOCTOROW: Oh
right, I see.
CHARLES STROSS: Doing something
that should be
impossible.
CORY DOCTOROW: In the back.
AUDIENCE: First of all, thank
you both for your blogs and
[INAUDIBLE].
But I wanted to ask you
both [INAUDIBLE].
Ray Kurzweil, the debate I've
heard about him is whether he
is scientifically grounded with
a very strong speculative
component, or basically
speculative fiction marketing
itself as scientifically
grounded.
I've heard the science
perspective on that, but if
two authors in speculative
[INAUDIBLE].
I'm curious what sort of
perspective you have
[INAUDIBLE], especially in the
context of this novel.
CHARLES STROSS: Um, I just got a
real strong sense of deja vu
when I read some of his books,
because I'd seen the stuff 10
years earlier on the Extropians
mailing list.
I should say no more.
CORY DOCTOROW: Well, I mean, I
interviewed Ray for "Asimov's
Science Fiction Magazine."
It's online.
And you know, the summary of
kind of where I netted out
with this is that there's an
underlying question that Ray
treats as kind of one on which
there is broad consensus, that
in fact we don't have any broad
consensus on, and that's
the locus of identity.
Not the locus of consciousness,
but the locus
of identity.
So imagine that you uploaded
a copy of yourself.
And you wanted to, like--
what's the command?
Tar -t, or whatever, to
verify the archive?
You wanted to verify your
archive, right?
So one way to do that is you
could do a Turing test.
So two Chinese rooms--
you're in one, the uploaded
you is in the other, and
someone gives you stimulus.
They ask you questions, and if
the questions line up, you
know, the answers line up, the
same identical response to
stimulus, we'd say, OK,
it's the same person.
But there's a problem with that,
which is that if I took
you five years ago and stuck
you in a room and then took
you today, you wouldn't
give the same answers.
So there's a kind of
reductionist story, there's a
kind of Socratic dialogue that
takes place in the Singularity
literature, in which you have
someone who's a skeptic and
someone who's a guru
or a believer.
And the skeptic says, if you
upload me into a computer, I
will no longer be me.
And the guru leads them through
this dialogue where
they say, well, what if I
replaced one of your legs with
a robot leg, would
you still be you?
And the person says, why, of
course I'd still be me.
And what if we moved it one
inch higher, right?
And you just keep going till
you get to the brain stem.
And then you go, well, at what
point do you cease to be you?
Or you can do it in the other
direction, right?
Your pupil is the end of your
optic nerve, so you can see--
just like your teeth are the
end of your skeleton.
Right?
So if I took that part of your
brain right there that we can
all see and I replaced that
with a microchip--
as there's already CCDs that
people hook up to optic nerves
and experiment in a medical
context-- are you still you?
Part of your brain
is now a machine.
And you just go millimeter by
millimeter back, again, until
you reach the brain stem, and
you say, at what point do you
cease to be you?
And that sounds plausible.
It's a nice word game to play.
But actually, if you were a
concert pianist and I cut your
hands off and replace them
with robot hands,
you wouldn't be you.
Right?
If I put you prior to this gross
insult to your anatomy
and you afterwards in Chinese
rooms and ask you questions,
you wouldn't be you.
And I've come to think that
although we exist in a
continuum of identity, from
moment to moment the answers,
the difference between the
answers that we would give in
the Chinese room experiment are
near enough to identical
as makes no never-mind, that
across certain distances or
across certain singularities,
across certain punctuated
events, those answers change.
In the same way that all of the
stages between Latin and
French are mutually
intelligible, but Latin and
French are not mutually
intelligible.
Or all of the intermediate
stages between speciation in
two finches are mutually
compatible, but once you're
fully speciated, by definition,
you're no longer
compatible.
And that because we can't agree
on who I am and who you
are and where the locus of
identity is-- because we've
never had to answer
the question.
Because we've never had a
meaningful way to say, well,
here's two of you, which
one is the real one?
That because we can't do that,
that there's this enormous
question that we elide when
we talk about uploading.
This is an important question
in the Kurzweilian sense.
Maybe not in the
Vingean sense.
"Are you still you once you're
in the computer?" is a
question that matters
a lot to you.
Right?
It may not matter a lot to the
Singularity, but it matters an
awful lot to you.
And if we can't even agree on
what "you" means, then I think
we have a hard time answering
that question.
And I think that little cheap
Socratic dialogue is a trick
that is used to misdirect us,
deliberately or otherwise,
from a pretty important
existential
problem that's new.
Or at least new in the
sense that it may be
non-hypothetical in
the near future.
And that newness is something
that we have yet to come to
grips with.
CORY DOCTOROW: On the other
hand, I will add that it is an
interestingly constrained
question, because it is one
that is subject to empirical
experimentation.
CORY DOCTOROW: Mmhm.
Sure.
CHARLES STROSS: Although I
wouldn't recommend starting
with human volunteers.
Take something like lobsters.
CORY DOCTOROW: Charlie
has written
about uploaded lobsters.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So this thing about
uploading yourself,
and is it still you?
We can have a much smaller
version of the argument.
People who change their
hairstyle and say, oh, this is
the new me.
Just that very statement, that
by changing your hairstyle,
you become a new you, should
really give us the answer of
what happens when you
upload yourself.
CORY DOCTOROW: Well, you could
change nothing, and someone
could fly an airplane into a
building in your hometown, and
you would still-- and you would
probably be a different
person, too, right?
CHARLES STROSS: Let me ask a
different variant on it.
Here's a tablet.
Is this tablet part of me?
Obviously not.
OK, take into account the
combination of programs,
configuration, and data loaded
onto it, including chunks
which definitely came out of my
mind which are part of my
extended phenotype.
Is it part of me?
This is the argument on, are
tools part of identity?
We relate to them as if they're
extensions of our body.
Or are they separate?
It's sort of reverse of
the amputation and
artificial leg question.
CORY DOCTOROW: Mmhm.
Sure.
I mean, if you've got 100 times
more non-human cells in
your body, symbiotes, than
you have human cells--
which you do--
and if you remove them, you
would die-- which you would--
then who are you?
Are you a colony organism
that just thinks that
it's a single entity?
Or are you a ship on which
many passengers, that are
nevertheless somehow under
your volitional control,
hitch a ride on?
I mean, I think that these are
really important, weird
questions that we haven't
quite answered.
CHARLES STROSS: Oh.
Another version.
Life-logging.
I assume everybody's more or
less familiar with the idea of
life-logging.
You carry video cameras, mics,
GPS, other data recorders
around with you-- blood
pressure monitors--
CORY DOCTOROW: Compromised
mobile phones.
CHARLES STROSS: Yep.
Internal biological monitors.
You record everything.
You tag everything.
We have reasonable
speech-to-text.
We have reasonable recognition
of objects in the real world.
I mean, you guys here have been
part of a company that's
developed a lot of that stuff.
OK.
Imagine everything around me is
logged and tagged for the
whole of my life.
But you can then ask it
questions, such as, who was
having lunch with in such and
such a city on Tuesday
the 2nd last year?
And get answers back.
If you then couple that with
an avatar generated from
recordings of me, and some sort
of model that has via a
genetic algorithm been evolved
to try and give the same
responses as me, you then
have a artificial
representative of me.
An avatar.
Now suppose somebody
shoots me.
Is the avatar part of me?
Is it me?
One argument is no.
Another argument is well,
it's a component of
your extended identity.
It's what's left over.
CORY DOCTOROW: In the same way
that all the stuff in your
hard drive is, too.
Or this was a big question
when AOL did
that search term dump.
Your search queries
are an enormously
personal part of you.
I just--
I don't know if anyone any of
you saw, if you read Boing
Boing, I wrote it an obit for a
good friend of mine in June.
He was a hacker, free software
guy who was my age.
Died in his sleep totally
randomly.
He was a vegetarian who did
yoga and rode a bicycle
everywhere but had a cerebral
hemorrhage.
It was like, you just multiply
all the blood vessels in your
body by the number of heartbeats
you have and divide
it by the failure rate, and at
a certain point, some of you
will have brain hemorrhages.
So his family, not very
technical, didn't know what to
do with his computer.
It was on when he died, logged
in to his [INAUDIBLE] machine.
And they were just going to turn
it off and stick it in a
box until they could
figure it out.
And I was like, you know, if you
do that, you'll lose it.
The platters will seize up.
The computer-- you'll get
burgled and it'll get stolen.
It'll get shorted out.
It'll get wet.
And this is him, right?
This is everything, all the
software he's written,
everything he's done since he
was about 14 years old, copied
over and over and over.
And I went with a hard
drive over to
the commune he founded--
he lived in a kind of anarchist
commune in Toronto--
and copied off terabyte of his
data, which was mostly nested
backups of his old data, which
like many of us, he hadn't
really thought this through, and
didn't really plan on what
people would do with his
data after he was dead.
But yes, by the time I watched
our sync copy the 10 millionth
copy of Python, I was like, I
probably should have de-duped
this before I started.
But in any event, I stuck it
on S3 and paid for 10 years
storage so they could figure out
what to do it in 10 years.
But this really was
part of him.
And I think we haven't come
to grips at all with
what to do with that.
And I think we're already kind
of symbolically starting to
deal with what to do with
backups of people, because
there's an enormous amount
of personal information.
Charlie, you were saying
the other day that--
what was the year?
2050?
CHARLES STROSS: Around--
yeah, some estimates.
Around 2050, whatever social
networks are still running, we
can expect internet adoption to
have penetrated the entire
population of Earth who are
functionally literate, and
even some who aren't, around
2050, which is the flip-over
point at which more people
on the internet will
be dead than alive.
Because by then, the internet
will have been around for, in
one form or another, about 80
years and will have hit
serious take-off 50
years earlier.
A lot of people will have been
on there and will have died.
I mean, I would like to think
I'll be alive in 2050, but I'm
not optimistic, because
I would be 86.
CORY DOCTOROW: If any of you
want to quit your job and do a
start-up, I've got
a great idea.
Not that I'm going to start--
I'm going to write about it for
"The Guardian" this week
because I owe them a column.
But basically the idea is that
you just deploy an army of biz
dev people in, like, sailcloth
blue suits and khakis to go
around and do deals with all
the major social networks--
Facebook and Google
and so on--
to authenticate that someone
is dead and that there is
someone who is empowered
to receive their login
credentials.
And then you sell it to
funeral directors.
And so you come and you're,
like, oh, I'm grieving, I
don't know what to do.
And as they're trying to upsell
you on a giant, tacky
aluminum coffin, they're also
saying, by the way, we have a
service that we work with.
They're very good, and they will
make sure that your loved
one's Facebook, Gmail, and so
on, all those credentials, are
turned over to you so
you can manage them.
We deal with all the
CAs and so on.
It's a single point
of contact.
And they'll just turn over the
credentials to you on a
certified basis.
I think it would be
a big business.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
CORY DOCTOROW: Really?
AUDIENCE: I've seen
[INAUDIBLE].
CORY DOCTOROW: With--?
AUDIENCE: I don't
remember where.
CORY DOCTOROW: There are ones
that will set up a memorial to
export your Facebook, but
there's no one, as far as I
know, who will ease--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
CORY DOCTOROW: Yeah, but there's
no one who can do the
authentication credentials.
That's the hard part, right?
It's to like, convince Yahoo or
Google or Facebook to hand
over auth credentials
to someone.
And that's the part that's like
logistically intensive
and relationship-intensive.
Yeah, there are tons of
companies that'll do an online
memorial, where you can
export the Facebook
data and get it in.
But you need to have the login
credentials to do it.
So unless you know how to log
into that person's account,
then you're hosed.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
CORY DOCTOROW: For not dying.
Yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
CORY DOCTOROW: Yeah.
Yeah, Sam?
AUDIENCE: So I've always noticed
that in singularity
and sort of uploader culture,
it's never mentioned who
administers the systems
that run it.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: You want to get a
Singularity [INAUDIBLE] now?
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: I am [INAUDIBLE],
yeah.
I think, if we're the people
who are probably more
interested in uploading,
but who are we gonna
trust to run us?
AUDIENCE: Google.
CHARLES STROSS: Actually,
there's one novel I can think
of where the novelist
in question tackled
that question head-on--
Iain M. Banks in "Surface
Detail." And you probably
won't like the answer.
[LAUGHTER]
CORY DOCTOROW: You know, we
kind of tackle it in this.
I mean, for one thing, we have
a whole group of people who
are uploaded and kind
of LARP bureaucracy.
They feel like you need a
bureaucracy, and so they go to
work and they do boring work.
Even though it's all automated,
they feel like
someone needs to do it.
They're called the
World Gov LARP.
CHARLES STROSS: And the clothing
for their LARP is
really boring.
CORY DOCTOROW: Yeah.
Yeah.
And we do actually, we do have
some self-governed systems
that run Capabilities
environment.
So there's a Capabilities bar
where you can't get into a
fight unless the other person
allows you to fight with them,
and then you have a contract
that allows you to fight.
And there's things like, you
could be diffed back if you
violate the contract and so on.
It's--
it's a pretty fun bar.
AUDIENCE: "Permutation City,"
I think, has a pretty
interesting take on it,
that essentially it
doesn't require hardware.
But that also has some really
good tips about what it would
be like to be [INAUDIBLE].
CORY DOCTOROW: Yeah.
CHARLES STROSS: But bear in
mind, Greg Egan has sort of
recanted fairly valiantly
against the approach to AI via
genetic algorithms he was
pitching in that novel.
Doesn't like it anymore.
Has ethical qualms.
Over--
CORY DOCTOROW: I'm sorry.
PRESENTER: That's all
we have time for.
I'm sorry.
CORY DOCTOROW: Oh, we did have
someone who hadn't asked a
question at all.
PRESENTER: Uh, oh, OK.
CORY DOCTOROW: Just
one quick one?
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Uh, so the worlds you
write about and the worlds
you live in are a little bit
different, today, at least.
How do you stay creative?
How do you generate
these ideas?
Do you have a process?
CORY DOCTOROW: There's a post
office box in Schenectady.
You send a self-addressed
stamped envelope and they send
you back science
fiction ideas.
[LAUGHTER]
CHARLES STROSS: There's--
actually, in my case, there's
a little closet in the
basement of the MIT Media Lab,
and I have to report there for
reprogramming every two years.
[LAUGHTER]
CORY DOCTOROW: That's the one
Aaron Swartz got busted for
sneaking into.
No.
It's the 21st century.
If you can't come up with cool
science fiction ideas before
breakfast, you're not paying
attention, you know?
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]